hi I'm Sebastian fun and I've been
working on self-driving cars for
unbelievably long my team won the DARPA
Grand Challenge became in second the
urban zones but I hired the people from
the urban challenge I founded the Google
self-driving car team and I ran it
longer than anybody else so I know a
thing or two BOTS have laminar with this
new program you get a chance to learn
from the best people in the world all
the secrets about this amazing new
technology we've put together a very
comprehensive introductory level program
and self-driving cars it should be
accessible to everybody why should you
take it well it's a fascinating
technology it's really amazing new stuff
and it empowers you to become quite an
expert yet but make a big step towards
becoming experts in self-driving cars so
please enroll
[Music]